the biggest benefit to me with
intermittent fasting is not body
composition changes it's not cognitive
awareness it's the element of Mastery
that comes with it and that's where
people miss the boat because you cannot
contest that you can sit here and you
can fight every single nook and cranny
of intermittent fasting based upon where
you stand and your views of nutrition
time restricted feeding you cannot argue
with me that there is an element of
Mastery that comes into place with
abstaining from something
for the people that don't know you
what's your background what do you do
it's a guy on the internet man
I'm just you know for me I'm a
translator of science I'm not a
biochemist I don't pretend to be one I I
take the research I know how to read a
paper very well
and I tend to get really overly excited
about stuff like that and then I
translate it and I try to put it into
layman terms and do a decent job at
articulating complex subject matter into
a way that's digestible for people so
that they can have a chance to really
review the research and understand and
Put Another Brick in the Wall for
themselves towards being healthier
having more vitality and just being
better humans why did you get interested
in that
I realized not that long ago that I'm
not that great at many things uh but I'm
decent at a lot of things and I realize
the one thing that I am really good at
is articulating and communicating
and for a long time I tried to fight
that I always wanted to be the strongest
guy in the room or the smartest guy in
the room I always wanted to kind of you
know face adversity and and I just wanna
I wanna be that guy and then I realized
that you know what it's actually really
good to be a good effective communicator
and I started leaning into that and the
moment that I leaned into that and I fed
the stallion starved the pony so to
speak I realized that I can take all
these things that I'm halfway decent at
but really get people excited about them
with my ability to communicate it
talk to me about childhood for you you
have a very interesting background
what was that like yeah my childhood you
know it's interesting I don't talk about
it much and recently it's been coming up
more probably because people are trying
to figure out what makes me tick
um
I came from what looked like a pretty
normal conventional childhood on the
surface uh
I had a loving mother and a you know
very loving father
I ran my first like 10K when I was like
five years old right so I I was kind of
got into running at a very young young
age
and then I ultimately I'm flashing
forward I ran my first marathon when I
was 11. and the reason that I'm starting
with that is not to say hey I'm this
amazing person look at me
it's because now as an adult and as a
father myself I look back at that I'm
like wow that's interesting like
what was my mom thinking and I love my
mom and I'm close with my mom and
everything I did everything with my mom
like I was always Along by her side
right and I realized that she did these
things and I wanted to be like her I
wanted to be with her and my mom would
run marathon so I would run marathons
too and my mom sort of had this
mentality of like hey well you know what
if you want to hang out with me then
you're going to do the stuff that I'm
gonna do and there was no real worry
about it it was just the way that it is
um hang on so we're talking age four
in order to be able to get ready to run
this I don't even think I really I mean
I was running like I remember running
like two three miles at age four five
and it was with Mom yeah with Mom you
know and I remember people because we
lived really close to these wineries
like we were living in Sonoma and I
remember people like clapping you know
like when I would go on runs I'd be like
way to go like way to go mom you know
waiting like it was cool I enjoyed it
there was never a moment where I didn't
like it like I always loved it uh that
evolved into sort of loving the pain of
it too which I mean you talk to
endurance athletes and that's a pretty
common trait they kind of almost had
this masochistic type feeling with it
yeah so I mean I was training at a very
young age for that and that just became
part of my life I was the skinny Runner
kid that was made fun of because it was
weird to run you know you're in
elementary school and you're the kid
that wants to go out for a run you're
the kid that decides to like run home
from school like I was a weird kid don't
get me wrong I was like the hiking boots
and shorts type of kid
so yeah I was weird but my mom exposed
me to so many different crazy
experiences to the point where other
kids thought it was insane like so I was
the weird kid as a result of my mom
always exposing us to very interesting
things when I was 11 years old I
backpacked the John Muir Trail from
Yosemite to Mount Whitney it was 230
miles took us 16 days and no experience
in backpacking and then went back again
the next year to do it again and did it
in 11 days and ran out of food you know
ran out of food for four days we come
back CPS gets called on us because I'm
emaciated
my mom's like no these kids wanted to do
this and we're like yeah no no mom is
awesome like trust me we want to do this
stuff
it's the childhood was just crazy but at
the time nothing felt weird about it
because it was normal to us and nothing
was ever we were never put in a
situation where we felt in danger or
anything like that but we we were always
subconsciously held to this very high
standard like you should perform and it
made me a very results oriented person
that unfortunately damaged me a little
bit as an adult because being a
results-oriented person has resulted in
me being well results oriented which I
don't necessarily know is the best way
for me to go through life
um but yeah there's a lot of nuance a
lot of detail that goes that goes on
there but it's just interesting
experiences that made people look at me
funny were you bothered by school were
you interested in school hated school
hated it
why I just well for one I I just always
felt like I could go faster like I felt
like very restricted and I don't mean
that in some conceited way like oh I'm
smarter than people that's not even it I
just felt like ah this is not a good use
of my time like I felt like this is this
is terrible from what age uh oh shoot I
got it uh it's a funny story I got
expelled from preschool the only person
in the history the only person at that
time in the history of Sunshine
Preschool in Sonoma California probably
can fact check this to get expelled uh I
just wouldn't have it I wanted to go
home and it was I tried to escape I did
escape and I wanted to go home I would
just scream and cry and told my mom came
to pick me up and said I don't want to
[__] be here and uh kindergarten I
made it through kindergarten but it was
like every day after school
I would I it was like I would cry
waiting for my mom to come home I'm
gonna come pick me up because I wanted
to go home so bad I just did not want to
be there I hated it and I don't know to
this day like why kids weren't
particularly mean to me I actually had
friends I was weird but it wasn't like I
was bullied like I mean I was kind of
picked on because I was the skinny
Runner kid but it was more just like
people Josh all the time yeah
uh but I hated it I hated being confined
I hated being restrained
and what was home life like
home life was you know it was as a young
kid it was pretty normal my mom uh went
to school she was a microbiology major
so but she never really used it
professionally she she was uh she owned
a landscaping business for a while and
then she became a school bus driver
randomly it was very interesting she
randomly decided I'm just gonna drive
the school bus because it's a way for me
to have Summers off with my kids
and a way for me to have the same hours
as my kids and that was a root of me
getting made fun of a lot of Tom's mom's
a school bus driver uh my dad
owned a bookstore in Oakland this was
very interesting because at the time
Mike my kid I don't really care
my dad owns a bookstore what do you do
but as I grow older I realized that this
bookstore Delaware's super newsstand
13th and Broadway in Oakland was the
only it was the world's largest
newsstand so it had newspapers and
magazines from all over the world that
would come there one to two days later
after they were released in their
respective countries
so as a result
my father's bookstore was like this
massive cultural Melting Pot in Oakland
where people from Pakistan Afghanistan
Australia whatever would come there to
pick up respective papers and whatever
from their countries
So Not only was it a cultural Melting
Pot where people all came together and
put aside their differences which is
very interesting it was also the site of
a lot of hate crime on the side of a lot
of so massive thing in history so if you
look up to Lauer's super newsstand uh
you see that it's been around you know
family business so I never realized that
until I was an adult I was like wow how
that's very wild uh my dad worked a lot
you know but he he was still a very
present father
um so home life home life was good it
was you know I could pick apart little
things everyone can uh there were
extreme situations there were situations
that I probably wouldn't talk about
publicly but nothing nothing that was
ever dangerous or bad
um
what about when you get into teen years
when you start to take life a little bit
more seriously yeah so by the time I was
about nine or ten I ended up with
obsessive-compulsive disorder I was I
used to have to flip light switches I
was always uh I remember these I had
these like hardwood floor in my uh in
one like transitional area of my house
and I had like these squares it kind of
looked like uh uh where the Celtics play
like that Courthouse has like that you
know uh and I used to I could only step
on the ones that had the grains facing
forward if I stepped on the grains
facing laterally uh it was terrible and
it was almost always surrounding uh
something happening to my mom like if I
stepped on the wrong one my mom would
die I literally took the step on a crack
break your mother's back thing like
literally so I was like I can't like I
can't it will break my mom's back like I
had this attachment to my mother
um so it was so I suffered with that by
the time I was in Middle School I can't
remember the term for it uh I was
pulling my hair out so I I had bald
spots in my hair because I was pulling
my hair out just from anxiety
um so I was put on you know
benzodiazepines at like age 13 uh but I
didn't really take them they were just
how common is that for a child to be
prescribed benzos at that age not very
common it's not not a healthy thing it
was like for an emergency case situation
right so it was in one of those things
where like it was not like my mom was
supposed to maintain control of them and
things like that and I don't even ever
recall taking them right so it was one
of those things where with that
I ran into all kinds of crazy situations
I mean it was just I
felt
constantly anxious like my teen years
were really really tough and of course
pulling my hair out led to getting made
fun of
and the only thing that I really found
control in was running like I can be in
control when I was running so for me
running became even more a part of my
identity it was like this is and that
carries through to me today like I don't
necessarily feel whole unless running is
a part of my life and I'm very
self-aware of that because it goes all
the way back to you know A coping
mechanism for me so teen years early
teen years were particularly rough for
me
what is happening with your sense of
your own body as you're great have you
got any body dysmorphia at this age
not as much now because I'm very aware
of it
um definitely went through phases even
phases of self-sabotage like when I
became overweight I ultimately had an
eating disorder I talked about this with
Nick bear uh there was a point when I
was like you know 13 14 where I used to
kind of like measure my uh my wrist with
my fingers and if I could have room to
like rattle my wrist around in my
fingers that was like a win for me like
no reason I didn't want to be skinny I
didn't care it was an element of control
all of this is an arbitrary measure that
you decided especially given the fact
that like the width of your wrist
growing and the length of your fingers
growing between the ages of 12 and 16
aren't going to happen in sync with each
other correct correct so there's nothing
nothing there's an arbitrary Choice yeah
it was the same kind of satisfaction
that I would almost get
that I'd almost get out of flipping
light switches it was just something
like but I also felt very in control
with that I felt like I can't control
when I don't eat I can't control what I
don't eat I didn't really have an
obsession with body composition I I
suppose if I reverse engineer it I could
think about it and say yeah like I
wanted to be lighter for running and it
made more sense so I was very skinny
very frail
um you know and then when I was like 13
14 I did discover the gym and I got
really interested in the gym and
actually the gyms I would arguably say
saved my life like it was one of this
because I was one of those people that
had I gotten into the wrong drugs at
that point in time I think it could have
been very bad I've always been a very
obsessive person but to come back to
your question like the body dysmorphia
now
to a certain degree yes because my
profession depends on me being lean in a
lot of ways so do I have anxiety around
not looking a certain way I would be
lying if I said no
um but it's in control what I'm
self-aware of it but when I became
overweight which we'll talk about in a
little bit
I reverse engineered that I think about
it I was like it's almost a means of
self-sabotage it was like it was me in a
way like I was aware that I was gaining
weight and like gained a bunch of weight
fast and it was almost like there's a
revolt against how I was before and uh
it's interesting it's just a very wild
thing I'm very self-aware
psychoanalytical person so I try to look
at these things uh
but yeah didn't you say something about
psychedelics when you were younger so
yeah so yeah that's what's interesting
so like when I was in seventh and eighth
grade I tried acid like I tried and like
I smoked pot like a crazy kid seventh
grade seventh eighth grade it was
and I know people some people judge on
that but I mean I was a kid I was a lost
kid right like what and I look back at
that now being a father I'm just like
what was I missing because I I feel like
my childhood wasn't [__] up like I
don't like it doesn't look like a way on
the surface right but there's certain
things but I'm like why was I doing that
stuff and I got that stuff out of my
system so young by the time I was 14 I
was like a total square you know like I
didn't even drink were you doing that
with people so generally yes I had like
two close friends that I would you know
and it was uh it was just it was weird
and I lived in uh I lived in Italy for a
semester went to school in Italy for a
semester when I was I can't remember I
was 12 or 13. I guess it would have been
I think I think I turned 13 when I was
there and that was a cool cool
experience because my mom said hey we're
gonna enroll you in homeschool so that
you can study abroad and take college
courses if we can get you approved for
it so basically we did we got me
approved through like aifs and I was
able to get college credits to study art
history as a 12 13 year old while
concurrently homeschooled great
experience but all the college kids that
I was around thought it was really fun
to like get me drunk get me [__] faced
pump me full or whatever the [__] they
wanted to
and for me it was like it was kind of
fun because I was the cool like 12 year
old and these I mean you're taking
people that are like 19 20 years old and
they're just like oh cool let's [__]
with this kid yes and uh I look back at
that I'm like I was exposed to some
interesting stuff at a very young age
but then you come out of that and you've
almost had a like hedonistic period
before you've even hit puberty and now
you're going through your teen years
being a little bit more how did the OCD
blend with being ripped out of your
hometown being taken over to Italy also
all of these new experiences older kids
coming in and getting you to do stuff I
would have imagined that those two
things would have clashed very badly
dude I think it actually like was a
pattern interrupt for me I think it's
actually I think it's exactly what I
needed and sometimes I wonder if it's
like I was like did my mom know this
like she my mom's philosophy when things
was like when everyone goes this
direction go that direction
you know where everyone wanted to put me
in therapy and everyone wanted to fix
the problem and everyone you know
hypnosis this nothing was working I was
still anxious I was still dealing with
Bob my mom's just like you know what
maybe maybe this [__] kid needs the
mountains you know let's do this maybe
this freaking kids needs some like
different cultural experiences and that
[__] helped me it absolutely helped me
but in certain ways it may have made it
worse but I I don't think keeping me in
the confined little box I hated my
hometown you know as an adult now like I
look back at it and I appreciate it but
I hated my hometown and I just couldn't
stand it I just wanted to get out all
the time and I've always felt like that
or I had always felt like that as a kid
I felt very confined uh in any situation
you put me in school My Town even my
state and I would sometimes develop
resentment towards it because I'm just I
gotta get out of this and the only way
for me to get out of it is to hate it as
much as I possibly can until I finally
explode and get out of it okay so you're
getting toward the end of your teens now
when do you start to gain weight so gain
weight at the uh probably like 1920.
Okay so we've got a little bit of time
yeah so I mean I put on some muscle and
that was a that was kind of the golden
period of of my my teens like right like
from like 15 to 18 I was independent
study
uh and a lot of the reason I did that is
after my mom and dad's divorce when I
was 13 uh I lived with my mother my
mother was dealing with a number of
different things
um both you know legally mentally just a
lot of struggles that I don't
necessarily need to go into detail but
you know she needed some help and stuff
so for me it was independent study where
it was like home school but I was still
part of the school you can still enroll
in school sports a really cool program
it worked well for someone like me but
then I also worked 40 or 50 hours a week
to help support my mom and to help just
kind of keep life going so from 14 the
time I could get my my workers permit
groceries so bagging groceries and then
I worked for a financial services
company where I would just like file
stuff so I'd work as many hours as I
could so when you have your workers
permit I think you could I could only
work like 30 hours at a select role and
then I would go to like a different role
and get paid under the table you know so
it's it's cool plus school but I was
independent honestly I was never
challenged by school like independent
study I could get all my work done in
like two hours for the week like it
wasn't a big deal and honestly I held
like a 3.98 GPA like it wasn't hard for
me and like school just didn't challenge
me of course I wasn't
trying to be challenged like I wasn't
taking I was like an AP English you know
I was in high English
um I sucked at math so I was like
Baseline math and just like you know so
I kind of skated through standing by
yeah just getting by but with good
grades and uh but I just was not
challenged and for me it was like I
learned the value of a dollar really
quick because I'm like okay well I know
how to work and uh that was what was
important to me was like how do I how do
I work how do I get all this done you
realize how much of an outlier situation
that is right to be working between 40
and 50 hours at the age of 14 or 15 plus
doing self-directed home school while
supporting mum whilst trying to learn
about yourself and the world around you
whilst dealing with the after effects of
OCD yeah probably is a lot
but everything prior to that felt so
normal right and it's it's it's wild it
well that's one of the interesting
things about
anybody's life experience right you
you're never going to until Elon fully
dials in neural link you're never going
to be able to feel what it's like to be
in the texture of somebody else's mind
you're never going to know what life is
like to live with somebody else and with
the Advent of the internet and social
media which kind of does give us the
view Through The Eyes of other people at
least in a small dose
but as a kid you know when you're
relatively sheltered you're not exposed
to as many people or things and you
don't have that ability to use theory of
mind
the life that you have is the only one
that you've ever known so it is normal
very much is mine as well I couldn't
imagine what it would be like to have
siblings as an only child so I'm like
well this is this is just what life is
isn't it it's you and Mum and Dad and
the dogs I got you know you don't know
what it's like to have a house that's
got cats you don't know what it's like
to have a house that's got blah blah you
know like I didn't know what it was like
to have a house that had it we always
every house that we were in Mum and Dad
love baths so we always had like a bath
so I'm like the first time that I lived
in a house with the showers when I went
to University
I'm like
your life experience especially if
you're a little bit more sheltered or
sheltered but like constrained sometimes
whether by availability or or habit
um can be difficult for you to sort of
rip yourself out of that and work out
what's going on I could never understand
why my sister who's four years older
when she went off to the Air Force
Academy
I never understood why she was so
manically
worried about me
because I was you know 14. I'm just like
Liz like
everything's fine like why are you
freaking out like so stressed out
worried about me all the time like
what's happening Thomas what's going on
Thomas and all I could think I was like
oh you're dealing with some serious
issues there girl
and then I'm like man I talk with her
now she's like you see why
maybe maybe I was one of the potential
issues okay so you're now working
full-time whilst doing your
self-directed stuff for school
going to the gym gaining a look but
you're saying that this is also the
golden period Well I felt great there
was nothing like it was a period of time
where I felt in complete control like
I've got Infinite Energy I'm in my teens
tired like whatever like I could work I
was making money helping support mom but
I was also making my own money and so by
the time I was you know 15 16 things
started to kind of mellow out a little
bit I didn't need to work as much I was
still working probably 30 40 hours
um and then at that rate I was still
running cross-country in the fall so I
was I was obviously I was a runner of
course I'd run cross-country uh I
discovered rugby my junior year so so I
played rugby I was a Winger I really
enjoyed rugby it was a way for me to
connect I didn't really on the surface I
didn't have any issues socially like I
had an what would look like a normal
social Dynamic but deep down it was a
struggle for me deep down it was really
hard for me to uh I had to work to
maintain friendships uh because I felt
like it's just uh it just didn't come
natural it was very introverted person
and the probably just came over I think
that was a a nurture versus nature thing
I think that was something that like was
manufactured as a result of working and
just probably non-typical upbringing
yeah just not having the time and my mom
also did kind of like make it seem
growing up as though anything
conventional was not okay
uh she used to pull us out of school my
sister and I pull us out of school
sometimes to like you know Screw school
like we're gonna go hike we're gonna go
do you know pull us out of school like
no parents would do that like but my mom
really wanted to be around us did she
want she wanted to be around us was she
wanted to groom us I don't understand
you know right
um but I enjoyed it because any
opportunity to not be in school I was
all about so for me the fact that I
could independent study didn't have to
spend time at wasting my time at school
could work and actually do kind of
something constructive
um so yeah I was still running not as
much running but I was starting to lift
and you know I got in pretty good shape
in high school I was I and then I met my
wife when I was 16 and she was 14. and
that's when things just got really good
like things felt great like I had met
ultimately what I felt was the woman of
my dreams and is the woman of my dreams
and then married her and have two kids
with her never been with another woman
in my life and talk about coping
mechanisms right like talking about like
my wife had a similar background uh not
the same of course but her family
Dynamic was very twisted and we found
each other and we just like locked onto
each other man like our messed up family
Dynamics and you know two divorced
families and we're just like we got each
other you know and I was like finally
this chick understands me someone
understands me someone loves me for me
short shorts and hiking boots
and uh
it's awesome so like that sounds like a
blessing dude it's [__] amazing do
you think about where you would be if
you hadn't met your wife dude I honestly
think
uh I
I think I'd probably be dealing with
addiction and things like that I really
do because like she is
the Jane to my Tarzan you know like
without that I'm just [__] crazy like
I would fly off the handle because like
I'm just so high energy so like I need a
little bit of that guard rail like I
need that and I think now
I you know I've developed traits and I'm
mature enough that
heaven forbid something ever happened to
her like I don't think I'd spiral off
but I think during those fundamental
years it was so unbelievably like
critical
what happens with the weight gain
so the weight gain came I always joke
about this because I never
out there in the internet it makes it
seem like I was this obese slob that was
always that way and I struggled with my
weight
the struggle was real but what people
don't understand is the mental issues
that came from that and stemmed that so
a lot of it started as somewhat of a
bulk gone wrong it started out as I'm
gonna put on some weight for muscle
right I'm gonna I'm gonna try to gain
some muscle and then
over time I just kind of stopped working
out got obsessed with uh you know I
ended up going into a commission only a
healthcare recruiting job
you know all this high stress stuff
where I was just trying to make money so
in the same stuff I was doing earlier
except now
I am completely on my own and I've got
responsibilities and my body just wasn't
working the same way that it used to so
it was very easy for me to put on muscle
but then I also put on a bunch of fat
with it too so I always kind of joke I
was like this was a classic example of a
bulk gone wrong but it wasn't like I was
bulking on six cups of brown rice per
day I was eating Jack-in-the-Box tacos I
was eating everything under the sun I
remember my wife's brother being like
looking at this uh baking sheet that I
had full of tater tots like just an
entire giant baking sheet I remember him
being like
that's healthy and I just remember that
such a snide little comment and I was
like convince myself like this is
healthy I'm bulking I was totally like
[__] Eric Cartman in Beefcake like
that
I was like ah weight gain five thousand
like as long so
fortunately I wasn't overweight for a
long period of time it was like two and
a half years where I was but I tipped
the scales close to 300 pounds at one
point and the fact that I gained the
weight that fast
at the time I didn't think of it but now
I think about it now I'm like what the
[__] was mentally going on with me this
was like some weird element of
self-sabotage it was like almost I'm not
a stupid guy smart enough to know and
self-aware enough to know that like if
you eat 10 000 calories it was like I
was stuffing my face trying to gain
weight I remember my wife even making
comments like being like you know I love
you anyway I don't know what you're
doing but it was it's crazy like you see
those
my 600 pound life you see that stuff
where these people are laying in bed and
they they know what they're doing and
they're doing it to themselves and I was
walking down that path and then I think
about like oh my gosh
my
sort of disordered eating past with
being somewhat anorexic this was like
the opposite of it I'm like holy crap
I've got like some serious eating
disorder stuff that I gotta work with
fortunately I was able to get a grasp on
it I always joke about the moment when
I saw someone that was an acquaintance
of mine they were driving down the road
and they saw me eating Jack-in-the-Box
tacos and maybe you've heard the story
because it's floating around the
internet all the time but I I went
through Jack in the Box pulled into a
stall afterwards and was eating my
translucent Jack-in-the-Box tacos
because they're so full of grease you
can see through them and this person
Drives By and he's not a close friend
he's an acquaintance but he just waves
at me nonchalantly and it was the fact
that it was such a nonchalant wave
that I'm like
this dude like he wasn't shocked by the
fact that I'm sitting here stuffing my
face this was status quo normal to him
this is how people see me the fact that
he didn't wasn't like oh my God the fact
that he looked at me and was like oh
what's up Tom I was like oh [__] I'm
caught I'm not guy I'm that guy and that
was it that was the moment people like
what was your call to action did someone
say you're gonna die no but I did make
myself type 2 diabetic I did give myself
hypertension I clinically made myself
type 2 diabetic so in a two year period
of time and that let that be a testament
to how a [__] up diet can really mess
you up right it can mess you up quick
and it took me like seven years to get
that [__] normal again but anyway that
all that aside
that's uh you know so this happens by
the time I'm like you know 22-23
you know given my background and kind of
what I was doing I mean there's a lot of
stuff that's kind of happening in the
background there with my healthcare
career healthcare administration going
into ancillary lab services in the
private Equity world for a short period
of time I really developed a really
strong knack for biochemistry because I
was essentially in medical sales so I
knew I had to be able to sell to
Physicians and be able to explain
uh various Lab Services salivary
cortisol testing explain these things
and I'm like I knew I was a really good
salesperson with that because I was able
to I knew so much about the body just
because I was so in tune of myself and I
got super into biochemistry just super
into it to the point where I'm like I
want to go back to school for
biochemistry I dropped out I dropped out
of college you know and I want to go to
school for for biochemistry I want to go
back and then I realized like you know
what like I'm actually making good money
doing what I'm doing without that and
I'm really good at what I do and
Physicians respect me and the community
respects me and the scientific Community
was respecting me then so anyway the
point is is that I had a good breadth of
knowledge
so all it took was like that Catalyst
for me to be like I gotta get my life in
order and uh
you know then there's this kind of whole
interstitial period between when I
launched my brand and everything like
that which is kind of there was some
downtime and
um what did you do to take yourself from
like what's what's the type of Diabetes
that you gave yourself and what does
that mean a lot of attention all that
[__] and then how do you go from where
you were to
even anything approaching Health yeah so
well type 2 diabetes I mean clinically
if you're over
125 uh younger guys per deciliter
glucose you're technically clinically
diabetic and you're fasting glucose
um or pre-diabetic and then once you
start clamming over like 140 then you're
kind of in that clinical range so I
remember my glucose being like 144
fasting repeatedly
bad really bad knowing what I know now I
know why that happened knowing what I
know now I know how I was corrected all
I knew was that I needed to reverse it
and I needed to fix this issue because I
looked at my wife and I'm like this is
stupid like all this happened in a
pursuit of building muscle
[__] up my body in a pursuit of
building muscle but also then losing
sight of that and [__] up my body in
a pursuit of making money
so these two vanity things muscle and
money
like could have completely [__] up my
life I did [__] up a lot of my life
because it took me years to get my
health back
and there's certain things I still
struggle with to this day as a result of
just like massive basic binging for a
couple of years but like well I mean for
example like it's still like my
testosterone levels are still pretty
tanked right I think that I did that
damage at a very critical age I think at
a time when testosterone levels should
have been peaking I was ruining them
right uh so you know things like that I
deal with that the mental repercussions
of it so there's a lot of attributes
where
you know maybe it's more difficult for
my body to produce hormones naturally
because at that point you know obviously
I stay in shape obviously I'm lean it
doesn't affect me too much like on the
surface but maybe there's stuff deeper
down to I take years off my life
possibly was it a massive hormetic
stressor that's gonna make me live to be
130 maybe I don't know that would be
great if the secret was Jack in the Box
tacos for you too the whole time
centenarian yeah it was staring Us in
the face the whole time so what you've
mentioned there is these two things
around money and vanity but as you said
earlier on you have this sense of
obligation to be in shape now because
your business relies on the condition
that you're in at least in part you know
um so that Dynamic is maybe much more
integrated maybe much more under your
control maybe much more holistic
transcended and included but it's
definitely still there it's definitely
still there and if it wasn't for having
my first my first kid my son
I think I might have been chasing this
for all the wrong reasons you know I I
thoroughly enjoy helping people
but I was starting to notice that I
enjoyed the validation of helping people
I didn't just enjoy helping people
and it was it wasn't like I'm doing this
for me but at the same time I was like
I'm doing this for once again a dopamine
hit
like this dopamine hit that I get out of
this was you know five seven years ago
creating content and I was like
before my son was born I'm just like I'm
good at this the brand is growing but
felt so [__] empty it felt so good I
or felt felt so wrong right like nothing
felt good and when I had my son you know
five and a half years ago or at least
when I found out we were pregnant so six
years ago six and a half years ago
things changed man like life just has to
change and all of a sudden like when my
son came into this world and actually
you know right before my son we found
out we were pregnant a few days later my
dad passed away so there was a lot of
very interesting stuff that happened
that sort of shifted mine like rocked my
world man
and what probably needs to be said to be
able to explain the full story
is you know you notice I haven't said
much about my dad
and I realized that like my mom in an
effort to like keep us with her all the
time sort of kept us away from our dad
and I don't think she was meaning to do
it maybe she was I don't know I never
want to speak ill of my mom I love my
mom so much
and but it's weird because I felt like I
didn't really establish a relationship
with my dad until I was an adult
and then pretty much as soon as I
established a relationship with him he
got a cancer diagnosis and
I didn't get it so I never got the
relationship with my dad and like to
this age day now with like my age I
crave
a dad so [__] much right like I
missed like and
we found out we were pregnant on
Valentine's Day uh 2017. and my wife
gives me a Valentine's Day card and it's
got the pregnancy test in it and she had
just found out that day too so like
we're like this is I almost passed down
like I you know I think my wife videoed
it The sneaky bastard like she videoed
it I turned [__] pale and I kind of
like put a fake smile on you know for a
second
um and then you know 30 seconds a minute
goes by and I'm like wow okay this is
gonna be cool like him there's no
turning back so like this is gonna be
awesome and uh
then we get my dad was in hospice but
then like the next day we get the call
that uh okay like
he's going down like this is you got to
come up to the Bay Area and come see him
and like four days prior to this
we lose our dog that had been with my
wife and I since we were together in
high school you know right so I was like
lost the dog found out we're pregnant
and then we gotta okay let's make a b
line up to see my dad so go see my dad
hold my dad's hand and uh tell him he's
totally incoherent you know he's out and
uh so dad you know uh you're gonna be a
grandpa and like he hadn't had made any
Signs of Life whatsoever like he was
just breathing like and cracked a smile
and hour and a half later he died you
know what I was like he waited and it
was like so just talk about just
powerful stuff all happening at once
where it was like I got this like a
little bit of closure but also this
sense of like
I don't want to go super deep but like
right before the night before my son was
born
I had a dream where my son was born I
was walking down my childhood hallway my
brother who's 50 years old or half
brother uh was there and just giving me
like a nod of approval I walked past
like the bathroom my sister's sitting
there giving me a knot of approval and
then I walk and I turn the corner in my
hallway and my dad I just remember his
big Italian hands of this dream that's
like reached out I didn't see his face I
could just see his hands and like handed
the baby over to him
and then I woke up from the dream and my
wife was going into labor is the
weirdest crazy thing man and like
with all of that like dude something
just clicked man it was like I gotta
like change like something needs to
change
and I don't I can't tell you what
actually changed man but like how I
looked how I created content how I
looked how I wanted to help people how I
looked at how I wanted to like make the
world a better place for my son how I
wanted to be a father that was present
for my son that my dad didn't
unfortunately have the ability to really
do for me
yeah long-winded explanation
given the fact that you'll know a father
of two
you have the opportunity to reflect on
your experience both with Mom and Dad
has this given you a new insight that
you didn't see before has it thrown into
harsh lights some things that you
thought that were totally normal has it
uh motivated you to be a particular way
as a father Yes a million percent yes
it's uh
I try to look at things there's things
that are maybe unconventional but not
necessarily bad that I look out in my
childhood I try to I do try to look at
the world through Rose Colored Glasses
as much as I can like I try to find the
positive and things you know so all
these things have made me who I am today
but the fact you know
I see a lot of times especially in
divorced families
where parents pit children against one
another and it happened to my wife's
family and unfortunately I think it
happened in mine
and I don't think that it was
necessarily intentional I think
sometimes it's human nature to kind of
like take you know like oh I want to
reach I want to grab I want to hold this
uh and those are the kinds of things
where my wife and I talk about all the
time like if we ever go our separate
ways like if something ever happened
like we can't be like that don't use the
kids like never ever uh that happened a
lot and I think that I look back at when
I was dealing with most anxiety when I
was pulling the hair out I was right at
the peak of the divorce you know and I'm
like what was I feeling as a kid so like
for me it's like man just to be able to
shower my children with love but be able
to just make them feel like they can
they can do anything in the world as
long as they put in the work and that
they're always going to have a safe
place
whereas I grew up thinking that like no
like you wore only really loved if you
perform
and I'm like
up until having children I kind of
thought that was the way it was supposed
to be supposed to give this tough love
like you perform you perform you perform
and you equals love let's keep a
spreadsheet you know where it's now it's
like
[__] man you can do whatever you want
Kiddo like if you are sincerely happy
and you are accomplishing and you are
doing good in the world I got your back
and uh that is definitely Transcendent
into how I create content because now
I'm like I used to live in this Echo
chamber with what works for me
intermittent fasting worked for me I
lost a lot of weight with it it [__]
worked for me 100 keto worked for me so
that means it's gonna work for you man
and here's why and let me give you all
the justification as to why and let me
create all this content surrounding why
why justifying justifying justifying
suddenly I'm like holy crap
I'm using my gift for all the wrong [__]
like I'm using my gift to justify what
worked for me and a motivated to inspire
a lot of people but I'm like man I can
reach Millions more people if I stop
leaning into my gift as being my
transformation and being my gift as my
ability to articulate complex subject
matter that gets people passionate and
excited to be the best they can be
sincerely less dogmatic less rigid with
the way we're talking about 100 yeah I
mean dude I talk about this so much the
fact that you cannot understand the
price that certain people pay to be in a
position that you think you want to be
in you know so from the outside the
three and a half million person YouTube
channel and respected by scientists all
over the world and walking around at
five to six percent body fat and jacked
and wife and kids and money and so on
and so forth
we go okay let's just take a small
inventory of all of the things that have
had to happen in order to contribute to
this right you know the entire childhood
the working from the age of 14 the
pulling the hair out the social
awkwardness like all of that all of that
um
that is the price that you need to pay
to be Thomas de Lauer and
it is I think it's very important for
people to see the human behind the
success I think it's one of the most
important things it's one of the most
useful things about having conversations
like this because
all of the people that I respect
who have achieved success have done it
in spite of a thing not because of a
thing and
you know for all that success looks
fantastic from the outside
a lot of the time people are running
away from something that they fear as
well as running towards something that
they want and the vast majority of
people Michael Juve the guy that does uh
is seeking greatness I think or chasing
Elite Performance the podcast
um I asked him he's worked with like
every High performer on the planet he
helped Felix Baumgartner jump from the
edge of space for the Red Bull Stratos
Mission and I said
on average do you think that high
performers are
happier or more miserable than the
normal person it's like by a million
miles more miserable it's like people
that perform people that are successful
on average are more more miserable you
go okay well what does it mean that the
people that are the most successful are
the ones with the least admirable
internal States
like what does that mean
what do how should we frame
success how should we consider
what we think of as
being
admirable desirable
uh
it's very difficult it's very difficult
to work out what you want the outward
success
but do you really want to go through the
pain and the mental texture that comes
along with it 100 man it's it's a Lewis
Howes asked me what's your level of
self-love on a scale of one to ten
and I was like dude maybe like a six
five six I was like some days I wake up
and I'm an eight but other days I wake
up and I'm a four it's like so maybe it
averages out to like five or six and he
was like really
and then I flipped around and I asked
him sort of the same thing I was like
you come on dad you talk to a lot of
successful people
and he's like yeah they all kind of fall
around the same as you yeah you know
there's a level of like I don't
I don't loathe myself but I don't love
myself uh
but
as I try to get a grasp on this you know
being self-aware of what drives me
forward what makes me what makes me tick
I really I try to be aware of that and I
try to be aware of like okay
just because my self-love is a six
that's doesn't mean it's actualized into
me performing at a six so I still try to
say like I'm still gonna perform like a
10. I'm still gonna eat like a 10. I'm
still gonna like live my life like a 10.
and maybe it'll fake it till it makes it
a little bit but so far it's not I think
that that's the way to do it man I I
believe that we lead with action uh and
I think that
small steps uh much more difficult for
your psyche to deny even if you are a
glass half empty kind of person
if you continue to show up if you
continue to do the things that are good
for you if you continue to succeed in
spite of your
uh absolute certainty that you're not
going to succeed
after a while you just have this
crushing weight of evidence that shows
you that you are able to do this thing
or you can achieve in the way that you
are that you're intending so one of the
things that you mentioned there was that
intermittent fasting was like a a bit of
a godsend for you uh it has been highly
contested on the internet
what is in your opinion as someone that
has spent a lot of time researching
practicing and coaching intermittent
fasting what is the optimal structure
and the most important foundations to
understand about intermittent fasting
the best structure is the structure that
works best for you as the individual
it's not the sexiest answer
but it comes with practice and it comes
with determining am I someone that likes
to eat in an eight hour window by
someone that likes to eat in a four-hour
window or six hour window the best form
of intermittent fasting is the one that
you don't get addicted to the one that
you can still use as an effective tool
without using as a crutch the best form
of interwritten fasting for the
individual is going to be the one that
you feel the best on the one that you
get the heightened mental alertness that
Clarity that you seek out the moment
that you start to do it because of an
arbitrary number
is the moment that you've already lost
the battle
the biggest benefit to me with
intermittent fasting is not body
composition changes it's not cognitive
awareness it's not this it's the element
of Mastery that comes with it
and that's where people miss the boat
because you cannot contest that
you can sit here and you can fight every
single nook and cranny of intermittent
fasting based upon where you stand and
your views of nutrition time restricted
feeding say oh well caloric restrictions
just as good well yeah intermittent
fasting is kind of caloric restriction
this that whatever you cannot argue with
me that there is an element of Mastery
that comes into place with abstaining
from something we talk about this with
caffeine we talked about this with
alcohol
food is a drug that we are constantly
exposed to
which means that it's incredibly
difficult to abstain from it in a proper
way and we are bombarded with social
cues to tell us that it's okay to eat
whenever we want
is that the truth
like should we eat whenever we want
should we eat ad libertine I don't know
I mean it's certainly real world because
that's the world we live in today but is
it accurate is it is it fair to assume
that that's how we should eat regardless
of your beliefs there being able to
abstain from food and having the control
to do so
seemingly gives me control in much much
many other or gives me control in a lot
of other elements in my life and maybe
that reflects back to my childhood and
wanting to have some control but there
are a hell of a lot of people that
respond in a very similar fashion that I
do
that's very interesting the fact that
it's about the story that you tell
yourself to do with the intimate fast
as much as it is to do with some magic
that comes along for the ride yeah I had
uh Peter it's here on the show yesterday
and he said the exact same thing every
study that he has found so far hasn't
suggested that there is any Secret Sauce
hiding in time-restricted eating Beyond
caloric restriction that there is no
um
I it just doesn't seem it seems to be
a very easy to follow
root for caloric restriction is that
your reading of the literature as well
yeah yeah and I think I think there is a
little bit of nuance there I think that
people that are severely metabolic
I think the people that are severely
metabolically deranged and have severe
metabolic disorder uh probably get
different benefits slightly different
benefit because there's something that
needs to be unraveled there and I think
Peter's actually even talked about that
it's like people that when you're in a
severe situation where you are very very
unhealthy then abstaining from food in
particular time Fashions could have
other advantages uh the autophagy well
autophagy is one of these things like
it's a word that's thrown around right
it's it's is it [__] it's autophagy
[__] it's not [__] but it's
definitely not this magic like it's
happening all the time right it's ha if
I go into a caloric deficit or if I take
some time in between meals or you know
what the biggest driver of autophagy is
is exercise right nobody talks about
that that's not sexy you can't say like
oh like exercise is going to induce
autophagy it's gonna induce it three
times more than fasting will
now there are different types of
autophagy there's macro autophagy
microautophagy there's lipophagy which
is where you're actually uh sort of
recycling fat cells all different
varying forms that happen at varying
levels based upon what someone is doing
fasting exercise General caloric
restriction and autophagy is dictated a
lot of times by many things but at the
very simple level ampk phosphorylation
which is a dimmer switch not a light
switch so yes the more aggressive the
caloric restriction the more aggressive
the exercise induced deficit the more
aggressive the autophagic flux
now with that being said it's like you
can turn that to a certain degree and
it's probably going to reach a maximum
before you start like degrading tissue
and having a negative outcome so it's
not a light switch where it's like as
soon as you go into a deficit you flip a
switch and you're you have maximum
autophagy
the argument with that is like okay well
intermittent fasting you're abstaining
from food you're ending up in that
caloric restriction phase significantly
faster because you're just not eating so
one could argue that you flip that
dimmer switch a little bit faster and if
you combine that with exercise maybe you
get more autophagy that's certainly a
valid argument but it does not
does not warrant us to say that like
intermittent fasting is the best way to
get autophagy not by any means okay what
about building muscle while fasting
so I think it sounds almost insane to
say like while you're literally fasting
you're going to build muscle uh it's
funny enough I think Peter attia had
actually mentioned some point in the
past like muscle protein breakdown and
muscle protein synthesis are always a
balance of each other and when you are
in a fasted State you have a high degree
of muscle protein breakdown that does
not mean that you're necessarily
catabolizing muscle what it implies is
that you could be breaking down tissue
from one area of your body and then
after the fast is complete when muscle
protein synthesis increases you
re-establish formation in another area
of your body or in that same area right
so as long as basic protein needs are
met within your eating period you
absolutely can build muscle with
intermittent fasting but I think there's
a line I usually kind of draw an
arbitrary line at like 24 hours I feel
like if you're doing consistent 24-hour
fast like every other day perhaps it's
harder to build muscle but if someone's
doing like an 18 6 three or four days
per week of course you can build muscle
I talked about this recently look at
your calories over the course of a seven
day period not daily like if you want to
be in a surplus be in a slight Surplus
at the end of the week if you want to be
in a deficit be in a slight deficit at
the end of the week maybe Monday you eat
4 000 calories maybe Tuesday you eat a
thousand maybe Wednesday you eat four
thousand maybe Thursday you eat 1500
it's like that constant undulation might
be good for the human metabolism because
it doesn't reset every night at midnight
to zero
what about looking at a fat loss plan
overall
if you were to design the
non-negotiables that should go into it
regardless of time restricted regardless
of how someone is coming into this what
are the non-negotiables for a fat loss
plan yeah for me
I still have to side with just about
everybody and say thermodynamics are
probably the most important thing are we
going to discover that to possibly be
different later in the life we might who
knows we always have to be open to that
but I think right now the evidence is
just too strong to ignore that that
thermodynamics matter too many camps
trying to like oppose that so let's just
all agree on that that's when you say
that you mean kaiko right you mean
calories in calories yeah which is a
very complicated matter it's not as
simple as people think but people try to
make it simple for the sake of content
but it is very complex because there's
all kinds of influential factors that
determine that right how much calories
we're actually burning how much we're
actually consuming uh did you juice this
fiber
et cetera yeah all kinds of stuff that
comes into play the other piece that I
think is a non-negotiable is having
adequate breaks between meals I feel for
me at least that's a non-negotiable and
the reason that that comes Under Fire a
lot is because that implies that you're
suggesting that insulin has to always be
low not at all I'm suggesting that we
have have periods of time between meals
that we do allow insulin to be low maybe
that's an 18 hour fast maybe it's just
having adequate three hours between
meals I think for maximum what what
would be the problem with just grazing
every hour and a half personally well
even an hour and a half as long as you
were just like taking that adequate
break
because you have this spike in insulin
and that insulin level needs to come
down for glucagon the counter-regulatory
hormones to release
which are ultimately going to allow fat
loss to occur like lipolysis as far as I
know
cannot occur in the presence of insulin
like if insulin is elevated at that
particular moment lipolysis cannot occur
at that moment you cannot be utilizing
fat while insulin is elevated that
doesn't mean that you never Spike
insulin that means you keep track of
when things go up and down your fat
burning mode isn't right when you eat
contrary to the whole thermic effect of
food thing like that's such a negligible
amount the fat burning occurs after the
insulin levels have come back down to
Baseline and lipolysis and made
oxidation can occur so I think
maybe it's not a non-negotiable as far
as the general world is concerned
because you could effectively eat like a
pea every five minutes and be eating 800
calories yeah yeah but I think for
adequate muscle preservation and for
maximum fat loss I think just keeping a
Keen Eye to that is very beneficial
um
other non-negotiables I think G flux is
a very important thing that's not talked
about enough uh that's energy flux I
subscribe to this man yeah I realize
this as soon as I started doing CrossFit
yeah right it's it's you know you know
what's crazy is uh I've had you know
Alan Aragon no uh he's great you should
have him on he's he's uh just he's
basically the person that takes a lot of
these major research papers and like
writes the summaries for them like he's
like that well versed so he basically
writes the condensed summary so he's so
good at articulating in fact I literally
like I did a number of videos with him
just because he's so well spoken on this
stuff and he and I were talking about it
it's like have you ever been in the
presence of
like an athlete that is just
crazy intense athlete with a lot of
energy it's like you're around them and
you can like literally feel their energy
compare that to someone that's on their
deathbed there's like a completely
different like it's they're literally
fluxing at a different capacity and
people don't realize that there's like a
mobilization cost or fee associated with
more energy and using more energy so if
you eat 2 000 calories per day and burn
2 000 calories per day and I eat 5 000
calories per day and burn 5000 calories
per day you'd say hey you guys are both
at net zero right wrong I'm actually
burning more because there is more
energy cost and G flux energy flux
involved at a higher rate of metabolism
it's almost like the mobilization fee it
costs it costs money it costs currency
to mobilize that much energy it's like
if you call someone over to replace your
windshield they're going to charge you a
mobilization fee because it costs them
money to get there so every time you
have an energy exchange it costs
currency the more you eat and the more
you move the more you burn overall this
is what I realized when starting
CrossFit that I'd always up until that
point because I was doing bro split
bodybuilding which means that really
unless you're doing incredibly intense
sessions how are you losing you're not
going to put yourself into a caloric
deficit through training you're going to
do it through food right so it's always
this sort of race chasing your tail of
like fewer calories to get fewer
calories to get lower metabolism to get
fewer calories now start doing CrossFit
I'm like okay my I need to eat three and
a half thousand calories just to not be
hungry when doing this and I got leaner
and I thought oh that's strange and then
I started training more and getting
heavier and getting fitter
and Lena I was like I'm I keep on eating
more and more food and yet I'm getting
leaner because I couldn't put enough
food away in order to be able to
compensate for the deficit that the
training was putting me in and I
understand I understand that you have
much more control over the food that
goes in your mouth than the calories
that you expend through your output I
Ben Carpenter came on the show and gave
me a really beautiful framework that
helped me to understand why losing fat
for most people through caloric
restriction rather than the increase of
exercise is at least something that they
have a greater degree of control over I
think that that seems to make a good bit
of sense to me
but for the people that do have it in
the tank to be able to go and do high
intensity training with Progressive
overload with some loading
multiple times maybe per day or at least
every day
G flux theory for me which is
the three thousand and three three
thousand and three thousand out versus
two thousand and two thousand out that
seemed to make a massive difference as
far as I could see dude it's huge I love
Ben by the way dude that guy is great
like he's fantastic he does a really
good job of uh just distilling things
and just uh humanizing it like he just
like so there's not not a lot of people
that I really like and he's kind of come
on the scene recently for me like I've
just and uh yeah just I mean just he's
crushing it kudos to him he's doing good
what else anything else so while kind of
dovetailing off the g-flux thing I think
the non-negotiable that also comes to
play is adequate diet breaks like so
that comes with the G Flex like it if
you just continually restrict calories
you're going to end up in that that
Cesspool of just and that happens so
much with intermittent fasting it's
relevant right because people say I'm
going to do 16 a fasting so they
restrict calories and then next thing
they know like they think they're
fasting but all they're doing is
restricting calories like sure they're
eating in a certain time block but that
doesn't absolve them of thermodynamics
right so at the same time there's like
restrict calories and then they have to
restrict calories more and then they're
like oh well I'm eating 1800 calories a
day or 1500 calories a day because I'm
inter fasting but I'm fasting every day
why isn't this working anymore well
because you're doing the same damn thing
as just restricting calories right now
re-entry now reintroducing calories and
being able to actually
get the metabolism back up to an
adequate State involves applying G flux
with proper diet breaks so what I mean
by that is you can't just say I'm going
to have a diet break and start eating a
bunch of [__] if you do that things are
going to go cattywampus you're going to
have compensatory mechanisms that come
into play that make you gain fat very
fast probably because you've driven it
yeah so people make the mistake of going
back to eating like they used to eat no
you have to increase the calories to
where you are at maintenance now which
is very difficult for people to
understand because back up gently yeah
well people don't most people aren't
going to figure that out they're not
going to say like okay I've lost 30
pounds of lean mass 20 pounds of fat
mass that means I need to adjust my
calories to Baseline at this for
maintenance so the easiest way to do
that is when you get to those stages
if it's possible increase your intensity
of training to allow for increase in
calories that way you're increasing that
flux while taking a diet break in a very
conservative fashion that limits the
risk of fat regain but still allows for
metabolic rate to increase in your RMR
to come back up right because that thing
going to allow you to increase metabolic
rate without gaining too much more
weight which then allows you to re-begin
another diet from the top with this
higher base metabolic right okay
how do you square the circle of one of
the biggest predictors of longevity
being caloric restriction with G flux
Theory yeah so I this has come the
battle right like I've seen this popped
up in the comments for me multiple times
it's like okay where do you draw the
line and this is where I almost feel
like is this where
fractal eating and kind of breaking up
how we eat could be beneficial like
because where do you draw the line of
caloric restriction like is caloric
restriction daily is it weekly is it
monthly is it yearly
who's counting how do we know is it
protein restriction we don't really know
is it mtor phosphorylation like where
where do you really draw this line so
that is a use case where I could say
okay maybe fractal leading makes sense
maybe you eaten a surplus or slight
Surplus with a lot of activity one day
and then lower activity lower intake
another day so that your net over the
course of the week maybe is a slight
deficit but you have adequate muscle
stimulus so still preserve muscle the
problem that you have if you if you
choose to do that is that it's not very
routinized life right you know so in a
sandbox perhaps or a petri dish
or a spreadsheet that makes sense but
when it comes to humans want to do the
same thing most days
I want to train five days a week and
have weekends off I want to do three
days on one day off I want to do
whatever right like a more the more
complex and fractal that you make the
routine the more poor the adherence and
compliance is going to be could people
possibly just periodize quarterly I mean
is that yes is that too much to ask that
would be that would be easier say hey
let's say let's look at this globally
over the course of a year yeah
let's say this quarter I want you to be
in a slight Surplus this quarter I want
you to be in a slight deficit
and just keep on going back and forth
quarterly you know no one knows the
answers to this obviously otherwise we'd
all be living to be a thousand years old
uh but then you know brings up the
equation of uh of the protein thing too
right like methionine and all this stuff
like protein is it aging us what's your
read at the moment I asked Peter this
yesterday so I can compare and contrast
your answers there's interesting
arguments on both sides
um I do think that the methionine
research makes sense I do think that
there's a a large plant-based kind of
skew to it that sort of distorts how we
look at that data I try to look at that
data objectively without sort of the
plant-based SKU and say how do we apply
this methionine discussion and protein
contributing to aging independent of any
plant-based discussion can this apply
for the Mediterranean diet where there's
still moderate meat consumption uh and I
think the answer is yes I do think that
being able to have adequate mtor
phosphorylation is very important for
adequate recovery I think that we are
this means eating meat eating meat yes
yes sorry so I think it's very important
for Recovery I think it's very important
for cellular signaling I think insulin
is one of the most important hormones
for longevity too and you know as a
peptide hormone it comes Under Fire as
this demonized thing but I think insulin
is also a catalyst for repair
so it is a balance but do you balance at
51 towards the mtor phosphorylation side
or 51 more towards the ampk side where
you're trying to be like I'm going to
restrict
um and with that I lean slightly in the
camp of
being on the mtor side being protein
being more important than restriction of
protein I think adequate amounts of
protein with caloric restriction might
be somewhat of the answer
this is an area that I find quite
confusing because I've got on one side
friends like Michaela Peterson Mark Bell
uh and also my own felt sense that when
I do lean more heavily into me that I
think I perform better I feel better my
body is better
um the feedback that I got from Maric
Health after I did my blood panel was
the same let's we need to get some organ
Meats in there let's eat some more red
meats
and then I see the other side of the
world especially the longevity
biohacking side the sort of demonizes a
lot of this I don't know whether you've
seen Brian Johnson have you seen that
guy what do you think of him what do you
think of his approach to the world so he
sort of uh got the approach of I mean
moderately low protein right yeah so
it's
you know other than kind of the surface
level stuff with the moderate low
protein I don't follow or subscribe to
his way of thinking so I can't comment
aggressively but I think that the more
that we can thoughtfully acknowledge
both sides that's that's really
important because again like we have to
ask ourselves the question like are we
looking at this through a wide angle
lens or not so like what is happening
globally like what is your protein
intake like are you in a net positive
protein balance is I don't know this I
mean you might be able to answer it is
like as Brian suggesting that you be in
a like a net negative protein balance I
have no idea uh he's coming on the show
in a few weeks I'm going to ask him yeah
I mean I still think a net like a net
neutral protein balance would be optimal
that means your muscle protein synthesis
is matching that exactly of your muscle
protein breakdown but who's going to be
able to figure that out right so that
would be the ideal situation so until we
have a way to measure that we're always
going to be in a slight Surplus which
could be more you know methionine could
be more issues uh facing as far as
longevity is concerned or you're
slightly on the opposite so for me like
how do we
attenuate certain things and activate
ampk and activate these markers that are
associated with longevity and caloric
restriction
while also maintaining protein levels
because I don't think protein is the
problem I think it's one of many
different elements and if you look at
the blue zones which people talk smack
on the blue zones
um and understandably so what's the Blue
zone for the people that don't know blue
zones are the uh areas of the world that
have the people that live the longest
you've got like Costa Rica you've got
Sardinia you've got Greece you've got
you know so Okinawa
and I did a video on this because I was
so interested I was like we focus so
much on the common denominators of these
regions we say oh well all of them eat
in a 10 to 15 caloric restriction all of
them eat low meat well that's not
necessarily true all of them eat ex-fat
all of them do this all of them do that
it's like you guys are trying to find
the common denominators I want to find
the outliers what makes these unique
what makes the Okinawan diet so unique
and different from the other blue zones
what makes the Costa Rican diet so
different from Sardinia let's look at
the outliers and take those outliers and
craft the ultimate longevity diet
and that video crushed like I think it
just like got people thinking there was
no scientific rigor to it whatsoever
other than what were the main takeaways
now the main takeaways of it were like
okay
uh Highway High omega-3 content uh
moderate polyunsaturated fat content uh
fruit polyphenols uh fiber and diversity
of diet so you've got things like that
okinawans eat a crapload of like purple
sweet potatoes you know things like that
right and looking at that still being in
somewhat of a deficit with that deficit
being more from like one percent to
eight percent versus a universal 15 so a
slight deficit
no scientific rigor to that whatsoever
it's just looking and pulling out liars
and being like what are the benefits of
these outliers and if we combine that is
that doing something and I just
encourage people to look at things like
that because we're so quick to look for
patterns that we forget about the power
of an outlier pulling an average so you
mentioned thermic effect of food earlier
on somebody that you're a little bit
more familiar with than Brian Johnson BV
shred
I am V shred what is your reading of V
shred and his work in the world of diet
and fitness I don't give two crabs what
V shredders does I just don't want
people to confuse me with them anymore
do you see why people confuse you with v
Shrine well we're both charlatan total
dude it's you're significantly bigger
and leaner than him but well that's a
plus naked if if it was a dark foggy
night I could see why people could
confuse you for him well isn't that the
most most of social media like I mean
it's a dark foggy night for most people
that's if you put in the filters on it
is yeah interesting I mean you'll speak
to Z later on about this but
um he did a
a series of adverts because you can go
on I didn't know you could do this but
if you go find out someone's
add manager account or something or you
can press on a particular page and see
all of the adverts that they're running
on Facebook
um and they went on and had a look at
all of the different adverts that vshred
was doing and in one of them they'd set
him up in a studio kind of like this
that had the same red curtain the same
mic arm the same mic the same uh like
Muffler top the same desk the same
lighting as Rogan's Studio
but he wasn't on Rogan and it was him
giving doing basically an ad read
fake on a podcast I'm like yo we don't
need chat GPT and AI to CGI like horse
[__] down our brains like people can do
this in person at the moment that I mean
brings V shred up to Zach later on
because he's got very strong opinions on
the guy
um I mean it's it's uh I I saw that
months ago and I actually screenshot it
into my team house look at this guy like
like he's literally faking me on Rogan
and now no I noticed that it's a couple
months later it's like circulating
around
um but I mean like if my shirt's off and
my hair is styled the way it normally is
like it's it's it's ridiculous I did a
video on it like uh I don't know three
four five months ago and dude I mean
hundreds of comments being like I
thought you were him like I'm sorry like
I was really confused I wait you're not
have you ever have you ever considered
that you might be like cleaning up V
shreds uh Public Image v-shred really
got his mind deep into the data here
he's reading the white papers it really
sounds like he's been educating himself
well it's it comes up because he holds
on to the coattails of your paperwork
the like the best comment I saw was like
you know oh well like I thought that you
had all this really good content going
organically so that you could afford the
ability to be more aggressive in your ad
campaigns uh you know and be very
superficial and simple in your ad
campaigns be more aggressive because
people are you know they're not
subscribed they're watching your other
content where it's very deep and very uh
scientifically backed yeah it's it's
becoming an actual battle that I have to
deal with where consider maybe a really
aggressive uh like design change like a
gender reassignment perhaps or like a
pink hair like grow it out I just think
one interview needs to change
and it might as well be you
well dude I had an idea what if I what
if I reached out to them and I said hey
do what you want with this ad it's all
good but I want to film an ad with v
shred and yeah actually like have both
of us standing there be like I'm Tom
stellauer I'm V shred we have opposing
views
stop confusing us and then just let him
go upon his merry way that would be fun
that would it would probably convert
really well for them yeah because it's
just different it would they spend
millions of dollars on ad spend a month
so it would get it out there and it
would sanitize you from him very nice
very nice you need to do like a you need
to identify I have a freckle on this
side you'll notice that his ears are a
little bit or like whatever you need to
identify those they're getting back to
Fat Loss one of the other so the the
other side of it we've spoken a lot
about diet high intensity infill
training is something that people focus
on an awful lot specifically for fat
loss I remember being at University
13 years ago my first Blood holiday was
coming up try getting into the gym to do
fasted cardio first thing in the morning
if somebody is thinking I want to use
high intensity interval training or zone
two to improve my fat loss what are the
principles the most important principles
that they need to know okay yeah with
high intensity interval training
I am a very firm believer that the magic
is in the intensity of the interval
itself
far too many people go into hit training
with like I'm gonna do one minute on one
minute off one minute on one minute off
that's not really hit training if you
ask me that's more just high intensity
training that's not high intensity
interval training the magic of the high
intensity interval training comes from
the fact that your interval should be as
close to maximal as possible
and if you are able to hold maximum
intensity for one minute you're insane
that's that's not going to happen you've
got 15 maybe 20 seconds in you so my
idea of high intensity interval training
is like 15 to 25 seconds maximum
intensity
and then however long it takes me to
recover to be able to adequately go at
that intensity again maybe it's two
minutes maybe it's a minute maybe it's
five minutes
probably not five minutes it's probably
realistically somewhere in the realm of
like two minutes that is to me high
intensity interval training
other forms of training where you're
going one minute on one and off that's
more like various forms of Tabata really
which has its place it's very good for
calorie burning but it's not the same as
interval training is that something
is there some Secret Sauce in maximal
output for fat loss I mean a lot of
central nervous system stimulation so
that definitely has uh an afterburn
effect uh there's definitely more
glycogen depletion because you're very
very very glycolytic when you're using
that intensity so if you're trying to
deplete and you're trying to get in a
carb deprived State there's certainly
evidence there for sure uh arguably you
won't even burn as many calories so is
it the most effective not necessarily
but it's certainly good for the
metabolism what would you prescribe if
somebody was going to introduce training
overall they want to add maybe two or
three sessions in per week so I really
want to add on top of an existing
exercise protocol where would you go to
we might not go to the high intensity
interval training would you suggest
something more like a Tabata I love I
love Tabata training I love I love Imam
style training you know for me it's like
every minute on the minute whether it's
cardio based whether it's resistance
training dude it keeps me honest a clock
always keeps me honest and it keeps me
moving keeps my heart rate elevated but
with an Imam I can fluctuate it every
minute on the minute if I wanted to go
relatively if I want to do
sets of five on bench press I could do
that in Imam fashion and taper and drops
it accordingly like you could do so much
with an Imam I know Marcus Philly is a
big fan of that too and he and I both
are are just big on imams it's such a
way to combine cardio and resistance
training but also such a unique way to
just do cardio like you could do I'm
gonna do 20 minutes of every minute on
the minute and I'm gonna have five
different cardio things that I'm gonna
do I'm gonna do 10 burpees for one
minute you know or for however many I
can do 10 burpees in that and then the
rest of the time I have that break next
time I'm gonna do 20 calories on the
Echo Bike or whatever yep so it keeps it
fresh it keeps exciting keeps the mind
going so you're not bored uh it's not
repetitive on the joints it's awesome
it's external accountability as well for
the people that on uh like CrossFit
build yet
introducing imams into your training
especially if it's starting to run out
of motivation
it's just like having a coach in the
room with you but the coach is just your
watch because even trying to do timed
dress periods when doing bodybuilding
you pick up your phone you like if
you've got 25 seconds or 30 seconds of
rest you don't have enough time to go
over and Dick about on your phone you go
look it's a 20 minute or 30 minute for
30 minutes I'm doing this thing as
opposed to saying I'm going to do like
four by twelve on this exercise and 4x12
on that exercise and 4x12 on the third
exercise and there will be a one minute
break in between you go uh it's not the
same it's not the same because you're
not accountable to the clock I'll give
you
two of my favorite workouts that I do
the first one is a descending pyramid of
wraps for any gymnastics movement so
handstand press-up this is great for
push-ups this is great for pull-ups
particularly so those are the three
movements I like to do this with most so
you warm up on the movement
however long you need to do that and
then you do a single set of Max reps on
that movement strict so be strict
pull-ups strict handstand push-ups
strict push-ups two minute rest then you
take 50 of what that number was you do
that
one minute rest fifty percent one minute
rest and then you do 25 with 30 seconds
rest four times so you do it 100 with
two minutes
fifty percent with one minute twice and
then 25 with 30 seconds four times the
reason that I love that workout is that
it's over and done with in usually about
eight minutes you have worked maximally
each time pretty much
you are basically creating an rpe for
the day that everything else then gets
percentaged off so if you go in and
you're feeling [__] hot you've slapped
great you've fed great you're hydrated
your energy is good you're going you go
oh holy [__] my first set on strict
polyps was 16 reps there I'm now looking
at eights and fours for the rest of the
day like this is gonna hurt but well
yeah but your 100 was that big for a
reason because you came in and you felt
great or one day you're going and it's
11 you go okay I'm looking at like sixes
and threes fine okay well we'll work
we'll work with that
um I really love it for that reason uh
and it's just it's over and done with so
quickly and you can always continue okay
what did I get last time on the first
one right I'll keep on pushing that so
that's my favorite for that and then
when it comes to cardio this is an
exercise I did on a concept two biker
ages ago but it would work just as well
in a row it worked just as well in a ski
you do a pretty high intensity as much
as you can uh
two minutes off uh two minutes on one
minute off six rounds one minute on 30
seconds off eight rounds 30 seconds on
15 seconds off 10 Rounds that's it
that's done in about 40 minutes or so
and that's a really nice recovery
workout and again it's the same starting
off big getting down to small those are
my two favorites yeah man I love any
kind of like ascending or descending
ladder like they're just they do
something with my brain they just work
like it's just like it clicks well
you're always motivated right because
there's always something coming next
we're always excited about oh you're
like yeah so I've got uh one more of the
twos left and then that's okay I'm
nearly halfway done and then you end up
doing this complex arithmetic in your
mind to be able to work out right well
I'm actually in terms of working time
I'm really halfway done when I get to
you know the second set of the whatever
whatever
um when it comes to
dieting and a lot of people as me
included with my Coke Zero
have a sweet tooth and don't want to
absolutely wreck our diet when it comes
to satisfying that
what are your favorite personal hacks or
best pieces of advice for how people can
satiate their sweet tooth without
pumping a [__] ton of calories and and
bad stuff into them I'm gonna give you
one that's really interesting and if you
clip this make sure you add this note
that this is mechanistic data okay but
it's interesting and anecdotally it
seems to work
we have what are called NSD neurons in
our hindbrain and a lot of times when
we're craving something sweet we're
starting to see some research that we
could actually be craving something
salty and it's kind of a gustatory
response with the vagus nerve and what
happens with the hindbrain and what I
have found and again it could just
purely be anecdotal or placebo
having some salt actually kills that
craving and it does for me like every
time I'm really craving something sweet
if I have something salty or just some
electrolytes or something like that it
feels like that just scratches that itch
so quick it's somewhat temporary like it
goes away fast but there's enough small
scale data for me to say hey this might
actually work but not enough you know
observational data to say 100 works okay
so first thing is potentially look at
throwing some element perhaps in water
exactly knocking that back because
you'll get a little bit of sweetness in
that too see if that blunts it
if the gravity force field pull of our
desire for sweet stuff what are some
suggestions on foods that people could
go to that you're okay with dude I'm
still a fan of like going for like 90
dark chocolate that still has a little
bit of sugar in it like don't be afraid
it's not gonna kill you but the
endorphins that you get out of the
chocolate like endorphins is kind of a
colloquial way of putting it but there
are basically flavonols in it that do
have an impact on neurotransmitter
function and that's been demonstrated in
quite a few studies that people feel
really good after they have chocolate so
that way you're getting that dopamine
itch scratched but it's not from the
sugar it's more so from the fact that
the chocolate and the theobromine is
kind of having that impact so that's a
that's a nice hack the only downside is
you know if you do too much of it it's
still pretty caloric right okay
another concern that I'm starting to see
people talk about more on in my corner
of the internet is bloating after people
have food
someone hasn't done a FODMAP diet they
haven't you know gone and done
restrictions on on the foods that
they're doing
what are the most likely culprits do you
think that people should be looking at
if they do suffer with bloating I think
I mean dysbiosis is a huge one I think
that's just a lack of diversity of food
within your diet a lack of diversity of
fibers so you're looking at very simple
gut imbalance okay if you imagine a
forest with wolves and squirrels
and you have one wolf and you have 30
squirrels and you throw a bunch of food
into a bunch of you know corn or
something out there and the squirrels
all eat that corn
the wolf might eat that corn but the
squirrels are gonna eat that corn and
their population is going to proliferate
right that's going to grow suddenly
you've got this crazy imbalance and
that's dysbiosis
but if you were to have wolves and you
were to have squirrels and you were to
have some possums and you were to have
like a nice delicate ecosystem with lots
of different animals and you threw that
food in there they'd all compete for
that food and they'd all grow at you
know somewhat proportional rates
and that's what we're really lacking a
lot of times in the diet and I know it
has a little bit of a skew that people
don't necessarily agree with sometimes
but it's not suggesting that everyone
goes out eats a bunch of fiber one of
the things that we do see across the
board is that it's pretty well
demonstrated that healthy guts are
associated with a diverse diet and
having diversity of different fibers
diversity of different foods in general
whether it's proteins whether it's
fibers even fats and this all has an
impact so I think in this day and age we
get really used to eating the same kind
of things over and over if you talk to
people like they don't yeah maybe I go
to this restaurant One Night in this
restaurant another night but they're not
diversifying their gut microbiome the
way that I think they should like I
really do try my best to like rotate
different vegetables that rotate
different sources of fiber all of chia
some days and then I'll have sweet
potatoes another day I really do try to
rotate that up and that helps my
bloating issues my wife dealt with sibo
with small intestinal bacterial
overgrowth for a number of years for her
kind of going back down to Baseline with
a Keto a diet helped her a lot but
probably just because it's eliminating
so much of those fibers it's eliminating
so much that it just brought her back
down to Baseline that when she
reintroduced everything sort of
recalibrated and I know a lot of people
preach that it's just not necessarily
validated with research I have a friend
uh called the meet Mafia podcast to be
heard of that yeah yeah so that both of
those guys same thing you know like
really really bad uh stomach issues you
are going to be on medication for the
rest of your life and they just went on
a really aggressive elimination
got themselves to the stage where it
seemed like their stomach had been given
enough time to
get rid of inflammation calm down
rebalance itself and then they slowly
reintroduced foods and it seemed like
what the stomach needed it wasn't
chronic it was acute and consistent and
once you gave that acute problem a
little bit of time to calm down there
wasn't necessarily an underlying chronic
problem under that and it just allowed
them to they can relatively eat whatever
they want
um it's fascinating man I I think that
you know the work that you do ban Peter
Andrew everybody uh is really helping to
educate people it's
a very I've been someone that's been
training for 15 years and I find it
still now I'm like is sugar in or out
this month like am I allowed it should I
do I have to should I have berries after
I have meat is meat and fruit cool now
or should I do I need to you know it's
it's the trends that come and go the um
murkiness of not only what is being
communicated but even the studies that
this is coming out of and all of the
perverse incentives I think the work
that you do is very impressive for the
people that are listening that want to
check out more that you do where should
they go yeah uh vshred.com
yeah YouTube is just Thomas the Lauer
just type in my name Instagram Thomas
delauer thompsonlauer.com but I don't do
much there unfortunately
um yeah and that's that's it I mean I'm
just going to try to keep on fighting
the good fight and just letting people
do what they want with the information
just arm themselves with the tools and
how about it from there Thomas I
appreciate you I appreciate you being
very open and vulnerable today I think
there's lots that people can take away
from it brother thank you what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
foreign